Well, first of all, thank
you all for being here.
My name is Marty Samuels.
I work at the art center,
I'm the associate director
of science and learning.
And I have two of
my colleagues who I
get to share this session with.
But really the session is
--and I'll let them introduce
themselves--
but really I want to focus
this session on an opportunity
to hear from the students who
are so kind to actually join us
today, so we can hear about
their experiences both--
how have they received good--
dealt with good feedback of
teacher evaluation in a class.
And what are some
examples of-- that
have been more
challenging, which they've
tried to provide teacher
feedback to their class
and has not worked out well,
but has it gone according
to their plans as a student.
With that, I'm going
to ask each student
to introduce him or herself.
And maybe start off
with a short story--
Wait.
Before we do that,
can we do this?
With the class chart thing?
Yeah.
Before we do start the
panel, I'm Johanna Gutlerner.
I work at Harvard
Medical School.
I'm a associate dean for
planning and administration
and grad ed basic science
and global programs.
A lot to say.
But we would just
ask you to start out
by answering this
question for us, which--
Jason, want to read it?
In case people can't--
Sorry.
Yeah.
Please write down
one question informed
by the previous sessions were
otherwise, which you would
you like to have our
panelists address over
the course of this session.
We'll collect those on
the card and integrate
into the discussion
in the second half.
But if you have
something that you
would like to make sure
we raise in this session,
this is just our
attempt to collect that.
And if you want to pose
a question yourself,
just please write your name on
the card so we know you are.
And specifically, we're lucky
to have our actual stakeholders
in learning and teaching here
in this session so specifically
questions that you want to
ask our student panelists.
So maybe we'll give you a
couple minutes to do that
and then they can
introduce themselves.
And can we also
write down questions
as they start talking?
Absolutely, yes.
There will be lots
more opportunity.
These ones were just--
going to ask some
pre-forum questions.
All right.
So we'll come around
and collect those,
but maybe now we can ask
our student panelists
to just introduce
themselves and then we
had asked that each of
them tell about a four
or five minute story
relevant to today's topic.
And then after we
hear from them we'll
have you guys
think a little bit.
We may ask you to
talk to each other,
so if you're at a table
with no colleagues
you may want to move somewhere
where there's other people
to talk to.
And then we'll return and ask--
have a conversation
about we heard.
Christopher, do you want
to introduce yourself
to the group?
I'm Chris Li.
I'm a senior at Harvard College.
I'm studying Human Developmental
and Regenerative Biology, which
is under the Scrub Department
Stem Cell Regenerative Biology
and I'm also doing a
minor in Government.
I've dabbled around in
the different science
majors for a little bit, so
I actually spent a semester
as a Chemical and
Physical Biology major,
but the divisions between
the different concentrations
are pretty subtle and so
it's easy to move around.
One story I thought I would
share is about a class that--
it was a pretty large class
that most life science students
teach here at Harvard--
or take here at Harvard, sorry.
And it's one of
those classes where
everyone has an
impression, I think,
before you enter the class.
And it's a requirement for all
students going through pre-med,
going through any biology
or chemistry major.
And this course
had traditionally
been taught by Harvard
faculty and was
taught by one or two members
who rotated back and forth
and there was a very defined
system of doing things.
And the other notable
aspect was that it
was the second semester to a
two semester sequence and so--
I won't name the
class, but I think
it might be easy to discern
what class this was.
And so the students
in this class
were obviously very conscious,
very worried about doing well.
I mean, most of them were very
interested in the material
and it was--
I would say most students are
probably certainly invested
in actually learning,
but it was also
an environment
where students were
focused on the outcome on
their transcript as well.
And so this course was the
second semester in sequence
and the first semester in
previous years have been done
the standard way with
a lot of PowerPoint's.
It was very--
I guess, packaged
for students so there
was very little reading
textbooks, synthesizing notes,
going to office hours.
Everything was condensed to
one sheet of paper given out
to you every week.
PowerPoint slides were posted.
They actually posted
annotated slides,
there were lecture
videos, so everything.
You practically didn't
even have to go to class
or read a textbook and you
could get that material.
And the problem sets
are very straightforward
and everything was
well done in a way
that I think was overly
generous to the students.
We actually had a professor
teach the second semester
of the sequence who wasn't
a Harvard faculty member,
he was a visiting professor
and he decided to do everything
completely differently.
And so he took a very
traditionalist approach, which
I think for the subject matter,
actually is not necessarily
a bad thing.
Everything was done
at the chalkboard.
There were no slides,
there were no handouts,
and he expected you
read the textbook,
simplifying things yourself.
And there was a huge amount of--
I would say backlash
or unhappiness
with this form of teaching.
He would also cold call and so--
I mean, it was a
large lecture class,
but he would call
on students and ask
them to answer questions
regardless of whether or not
they were right or wrong, just
get their conversation going.
And I think what we took
out of this was that--
I think a couple of things.
The first is that students often
are very vocal about feedback,
but sometimes that feedback
may not be directed
at the quality of teaching.
And actually, I
personally-- and there
were students in the
class who disagreed
with a lot of the
majority voice, which
was that this professor had
no idea what he was doing,
he was doing
everything wrong, it
wasn't supposed to be this way,
he wasn't teaching correctly.
Cold calling, according to
many of my peers and friends,
was a dangerous or unsafe
tactic in the classroom.
And there was a
lot of unhappiness
with the way he
taught the class.
It was also markedly more
difficult then years before
and I think that was also
another contributing factor.
And I think a lot of students
voiced disagreement with this.
They went to the
preceptor who's one
of the support members of
the course who develops
most of the curriculum.
And halfway through
the course-- actually
it was less than half way,
about a third of the way
through the course,
the professor actually
decided to stop cold
calling, to put a lot
of the material on slides.
And he was a senior faculty
member in another ivy league
school so he'd been doing
this for many, many years
at that school-- he
was on sabbatical.
And it just, I think--
personally I felt
that that was I guess,
a misuse, or at least
I thought it was--
the outcome was not
necessarily something
positive because I think
his teaching methods forced
students to learn in a way
that was not necessarily
what they had done before,
which I think is a good thing.
I think he-- there was
pretty much consensus that he
was a good teacher,
but the problem
was that people thought
the course was hard
and that his teaching
style made it different
or forced people to
learn in a different way.
And I think one thing
that I would say--
I guess the conclusion
of the story
is that oftentimes,
especially in places--
Harvard, where students
are very concerned
about the on-paper outcome of a
course, sometimes the feedback
whether it's robust
or not can be
directed at students
satisfaction with the course
rather than the
quality of teaching.
And for a bunch of
20-year-olds who
are worried about applying to
med school and grad school,
sometimes it's hard to pull
those distinctions apart.
But I do think that one
of the advantages or one
of the positive outcomes was
that there was a very robust
conversation about what people
thought and so-- to the point
where the professor decided--
made the decision to
switch teaching styles.
So at least I think that
conversation was there
and people were aware.
Whether or not that was a smart
choice is a separate question,
but I think at least there
was that particular dialogue.
Oh, that's so rich, we have
to be a little Q&A right now.
We can't just go
through all the panel.
I know I have a
lot of questions.
Any questions?
Thank you, Chris.
Any questions for Chris, for me?
We'll have more opportunity.
You mentioned that you
though he was a good teacher
so that suggests to me--
and I'm trying to understand
what that means to you.
As a learner it sounds
like though it was harder,
you felt like you were learning
more with his techniques
then you had been with
just having it spoon fed.
Is that correct?
Right.
Yeah.
The previous versions of
the course would be where
the professor-- the instructor
would have slides where there
were the--
this was a biochemistry course--
where there would
be the mechanisms
for the chemical reactions
and everything would be there
and then the problem
sets and exams
would just be different
modules within applications.
And for him, the way he taught
it was very much through--
kind of a socratic
method actually.
You know, what
happens if we do this?
What if we add this here?
What if I do this
different transformation?
Why is it-- why is this working?
Why are these mechanisms
attracting this way?
I thought it actually
forced you to understand
the intuition of the
principles behind what
was going on the chalkboard,
which is why I think actually
that tool is useful.
But I think for
a lot of students
it was the rapidity at
which he wrote on the board.
Not having-- you had to
actually take notes, which--
it was really funny because we
have these mid-term evaluations
and some students--
he actually--
I guess this goes to
some of the questions
we'll probably talk
about later, but he--
at Harvard, for
those courses, you
fill out an on-paper
evaluation from the instructor
about halfway
through the course.
And so he actually
decided to take
this in a very and advacet--
what's the word about legal--
not combative.
Adversary.
Yeah.
And he actually put--
that day after the
evaluations came out,
he had entire PowerPoint
slide deck with quotes
from the evaluation.
And he basically would go
through and explain why--
there would be criticisms like,
we should not be forced to take
notes in this class
because it forces--
which I think is absolutely
ridiculous for a student
to say.
And he would explain why I
think it's important for you
to take notes.
And he actually had-- as a
scientist he had evidence
and he pulled out publications.
He was like, students
learn 32% better
when they write
down things by hand
rather than just seeing slides.
He went through all
of these comments
and basically defended
his decisions.
And then the decisions
that he decided to change--
for example, someone
wrote that cold calling
was a very unhealthy tactic.
He said, I can see that point,
I won't do that anymore.
Do you think his
transparency there
was persuasive for your
colleagues in the class?
You know, when he
said, this is--
learning is hard and--
I can imagine he
may have said that.
Right?
I want you to take notes, you
need to generate knowledge
on your own.
Was that persuasive?
Did that bring more of your
colleagues along to his style?
I think it was very
important in explaining.
I think a lot of students came
away from that understanding
why he did things
the way he did.
I don't think it necessarily
convinced them or brought them
to his side.
I think even at the end of
the course-- and you know,
this is--
this was two years ago.
But I think it was a very
polarizing kind of cost
in the sense of
there were students
who absolutely loved him.
And he has a group of students
who stay in touch with him
and he comes back to
Harvard every semester
and we do journal
clubs with him.
And so there were
students who thought
he was one the best
science instructors ever
and then there are--
I'd say maybe 2/3
of students thought
he was a good
instructor, but the class
was something that they
absolutely despised
because of various reasons.
I think people understood
what he was doing,
I think he made that clear.
But I don't think necessarily
people all came on board
or agreed.
Maybe we'll take one more
question right now for Chris
and then we'll come
back at the end.
Yes.
When-- with the
fact that he decided
to change his style
midway through,
was there a discussion
among the students
about what that said about
the power of the students?
And how did the students seem
to feel about that power,
if that ever came up in
a discussion afterwards?
Right.
I think people realize--
I think for him it was a little
bit different because a lot
of faculty members, they
teach consistently and so
if a course goes
poorly one semester
then that reflects on
next year down the line.
But he was here for one
semester and that was it.
I don't think-- I think he had
a different type of pressure
in terms of having
to cater to the pop--
worrying about popularity
and where my Q scores will
be seen as gone after this.
I think the power dynamic
came more from the preceptor.
The preceptor for this
course was someone
who was immensely popular.
I don't think there was a single
student who didn't absolutely
love her.
And she was a good instructor.
She also was part of the
first semester of the course.
And I think students felt
very comfortable going to her.
She was also a younger
faculty member,
definitely more able to speak
to students about what they were
feeling versus he was a very--
he was in a little bit more
senior--
older-- just a little
bit in terms of age
farther removed from
college students.
And I think what happened
was all of the feedback
was channeled through
the preceptor who then I
think ultimately there
had to be a conversation
between the teaching staff,
her, and the professor,
and they made those decisions.
And I think maybe that speaks
more toward the importance
of having different
voices on a teaching
team as opposed to
the traditional,
there's one professor
and that's it,
especially with large
Harvard courses when
they are teaching fellows.
There's preceptors, sometimes
there's a head teaching fellow.
Those parts of the system
often work together
and communicate things
to them, push a course
in a different direction.
Thanks.
Thank you, Chris.
Brandon, want to
introduce yourself to us?
Sure.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Brandon.
I'm a third year PhD student
in Biomedical Sciences,
currently based over
at the Longwood campus.
I originally did my
undergrad in Toronto
before coming here
for grad school.
And while I've been
a teaching assistant
for some graduate school
courses in my program,
I thought the most
insightful events
I could share
about my experience
so far with the
teacher-student relationship
and how to evaluate
that, would really
be in the context of
working in a professor's lab
and doing your thesis work
with a specific supervisor.
The way our program works is
for the first one to two years,
most students finish
their required courses
and at the end of
their first year
they select a thesis lab in
which to do their thesis work
and their thesis research.
Over the course of my
undergraduate and graduate
studies I've come to know maybe
between five and six professors
on a scientific
and personal level
as I transited
through their lives.
And I've had an
experience to feel out
how different programs
and different scientists
actually like to
be given feedback
and like to hear how their
mentorship style is working.
And I have to say, in
the majority of cases
it's been that
there's no feedback
and there's no
evaluation solicited,
and you have to be the
one to give it forward.
In my undergrad, I worked
in three different labs
and essentially the
PI or the professor
who was supervising
the lab would not ever
ask for any feedback.
And it's a relationship where
you are a student in their lab
and you are studying
under them, but it's
a one way relationship.
And while the PI may be
comfortable with receiving
feedback from you,
you have to be the one
to initiate that process.
And there is no formalized
method for delivering feedback
to a professor.
And when I've come
to Harvard, I've
had a couple of different
experiences with this.
I spent a short time
in a relatively new lab
as part of one of my rotations
while I was selecting a thesis
lab to work in.
And she actually sat me down
at the end of my rotation
and she asked how I felt
about her mentorship style
and how she was running her lab.
And I felt really gratified
to actually have a chance
to be asked for my feedback
instead of having to actually
take that step and
walk into their office
and tell them something
I've been concerned about.
And that actually, I felt was
a really big moment and really
something new that I
hadn't experienced before.
And now that I'm
in a thesis lab,
I've found myself working
with actually a professor who
has really--
he has an extremely
open door policy,
he essentially has just said,
be frank with me all the time.
Any time I want to go into him
or his office with a concern,
I know he's there
and ready to listen.
But I also know other
students in situations
where they aren't comfortable
giving feedback to their PI.
They receive feedback on their
work, on their work styles,
on the quality of their
data, et cetera, from the PI,
but it never really
goes back the other way.
And there's no--
aside from going
to the administrative office and
asking them to really escalate
your concerns, there's no
formalized and maybe not so
serious way of giving feedback.
Because once you
start that process
it's pretty rigorous for
everyone involved and usually
doesn't have a good outcome
for the relationship
of the student and the PI.
I think there's definitely a lot
of ground for either discussion
or improvement in that area.
And as I understand,
it was also a topic
in the keynote this morning.
Any burning questions
for Brandon?
Yeah.
Just speaking with the
range of the faculty
that you've had the
experience of working with,
was there any observation of
a generational difference?
Absolutely.
In terms of the people who
were willing to take feedback
and looking for it and
people who weren't?
Yes, absolutely.
I would say the
ones that have been
most receptive to
feedback, definitely
are on the early
end of their career
or just starting their lab.
I wouldn't say that
older scientists
are less receptive to feedback.
I would say it's more difficult
to actually just give them back
because they tend to
be more established,
they tend to be a
little more distant,
maybe they're not
in the lab as much
and it's hard to actually
track them down and express
your concerns.
But yeah, that definitely seems
to track with how long you've
been in science for.
I have one other
question for you.
You mentioned this
should be done,
we need to solicit feedback
from mentees for their mentors.
And so there-- you could imagine
some kind of anonymous survey,
but that doesn't really get
at the crux of what you're
talking about, which is this is
a very individual relationship.
And while you've
heard your PI I'd say,
I have an open door, come talk
to me and you've done that.
I can imagine for other
students in the lab,
they might feel less inclined
to really be open and honest
and say all the things
that are on their mind.
I wonder if you have
ideas for how we-- how
do you encourage this
feedback in the lab setting?
What interventions
could go in to help
every student and their mentor
have these more productive
feedback conversations?
Right.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
I'm glad you brought up the
point of how to make things
anonymous because in this
kind of relationship I really
don't think you like--
there's no space to make--
to remove identifying
information because
a PI will typically
have between five and--
I'd say maybe four
or five students.
If they're receiving feedback
it's not really useful to them
if it's anonymous.
And I think that having specific
information and having--
and actually educating the PI,
that perhaps it's not really
criticism, but more
suggestions and improvements
for the future, and
changing that mentality
is more important
than saying, oh,
an anonymous student has
said, X, Y, and Z about you.
And really the
only formal process
I know right now, that where
students are asked for feedback
on the lab they were in and how
that went is when students are
at the end of program or
when they've graduated,
which may not be the
most immediately helpful
to the program, I think.
And one idea I have had is
really maybe instituting
some sort of--
not so much formal,
but some sort
of set meeting with the
professor and with the student,
maybe once a semester
or even once a year,
would be I think more
than frequent enough where
the explicit goal
is not for the PI
to give feedback on the student,
which is typically how meetings
with a PI and the
student go, but instead
for it to go the other way.
And for the explicit
goal of these meetings
to be for the student to express
how they've been experiencing
the lab and how they feel
about mentorship styles
and so on and so forth.
Thank you.
Signa?
Hi, everyone.
My name is Signa Mahung.
I am a second year at
Harvard Law School.
I also went to Harvard
College for undergrad
and studied Social Studies.
I actually transferred
here from GW,
so my perspective is
a little different.
But what I wanted to
talk about with you
all is actually
something that's happened
since I've been here and less
on the end of giving feedback
on your teachers performance
or whatnot or the course
so far as it's been,
but actually having
one of my professors ask at
the very beginning of class
what our goals and
expectations were for the class
and using that to form the
curriculum for our class.
It's actually a
visiting professor
here who is teaching a class on
Black Lives Matter In The Law,
and for a bunch
of us we're really
excited to take this class.
It's a smaller
class, to one credit
as opposed to a three
or four credit class.
And we didn't get the
syllabus beforehand
and I think for a
bunch of us that
was really scary trying to
figure out what that meant
and how much
reading it would be.
And when we got into our first
day we had some background
readings given to us and
he actually sat us down--
and our class is about
16 people maybe--
and he asked us to
describe ourselves,
tell us about our experiences
and where we're coming from
and what motivated
us to take the class,
as well as to say what you
wanted to get out of it, what
we were hoping for
out of the readings
and out of the discussions.
Which I tend to be
someone who doesn't like--
I didn't think about
that beforehand as much
as I probably should have.
But we all went around and
engaged in conversation
with one another
about our backgrounds.
And I think for me that was a--
it was just a great experience
to hear not only from our
professor and his background,
but then hear from
other classmates
and understand the perspective
they were coming from,
and what they were
looking to get out of it,
and see how much that
matched up with what
I was looking for, and
seeing that perspective
and understanding.
From the very first
class, that we all
have different perspectives,
we all have different goals,
and how do we help each
other to reach those.
And so for me that was a very,
welcome to HLS kind of moment.
And I'm really excited to
see how this semester goes
and how our conversations
in the smaller group
feed into that
narrative and are--
our syllabus has now
been formed so we
know what's happening
throughout this semester.
But it does seem-- and
even in our conversation
within the first
meeting of the class,
you could tell that he
was asking us and trying
to pull from our
different perspectives
and directing questions
at certain people who
might have certain
experiences and then directing
others at others.
Any questions for Signa?
I would love to do
that myself, is--
to leave it open.
But I wondered was this
invitation covering
the material and the
kinds of questions,
the contents, so to speak?
Or did it also incorporate,
how should I evaluate you?
How do we define whether
we've learned anything?
Was that also open
for discussion?
Or was it really just content?
And maybe this is
different because you're
in a law school than
an undergraduate,
but you can imagine at
the undergraduate level
at some point some things
are not negotiable or open.
How did it work in that class?
Because this is
one credit class--
it's called a reading
group and it tends
to be credit fail
so professors have
a very open
experience with that,
they can pretty much
do whatever they want.
The conversation
definitely was more of,
what are you looking for--
less in how he would be
evaluating us, but more
on how he structures
our reading the content,
making sure that for--
this wasn't necessarily like
a waste of time class for us.
He wanted it to be
specific to what
we needed out of it, what we
were trying to get out of it.
Thank you.
Disha?
Hi, everybody.
I'm Disha.
I am an undergraduate at
Harvard College studying
Chemical and Physical Biology.
I'm a junior with a secondary
in Computer Science.
And I've taken a
bunch of classes
in the Humanities,
some in Engineering
so I can really speak to a
pretty broad, diverse array
of what Harvard
College has to offer.
On campus here, I'm also
a course facilitator
for Internal Life Sciences
and I am a peer advisor
for the incoming freshmen so
I've talked to a lot of them
about their experiences
choosing courses.
And I also teach
dance and poetry
to Cambridge Middle
School children
so I understand how hard the
teaching side of it is as well.
I would just like to start with
an anecdote that's a little bit
similar to Chris's.
It's about a large Life
Science course here on campus
and my experience with
the mid-year evaluation
and the students
experience as a whole.
This course is pretty
required for a lot
of students pursuing both
biology and chemistry,
but also pre-med.
It was taught this year--
that I was taking it by a new
faculty member who was young,
still establishing
himself, still
learning the ropes of
how to teach at Harvard.
And there were mixed reviews
of his teaching style
early on in the class.
There are a lot of
people who were wanting
to be able to ask more questions
during the lecture, which
considering it's a very
large lecture style class,
it's pretty difficult
to take questions
within just the one
hour that the professor
has for instruction.
So it's understandable.
But there was a lot
of feedback and push
during the mid-year
evaluation time
for him to be able to
take more questions,
for the lecture slides to
be printed on larger papers
because we had all these
chemical reactions that should
probably have been printed
on one slide instead
of two slides per page.
For him to hold more
frequent office hours.
Basically the way he approached
this was very upfront.
I talked to the
preceptor of the course
later on person-to-person
and office hours.
And she basically told me that
he had gone through and read
every single one of
the 300 evaluations
that every single
student had submitted
during the mid-year
evaluation period.
And he took those
quite personally
sometimes because they
were quite hard to read.
It was his first year
teaching so there
was a lot of pretty
candid feedback.
But he went through and
then personally addressed
the entire class
in a lecture that
actually happened on
my birthday, which
is around the mid-year time.
With the feedback that basically
he had gotten and said,
these are the things that I
am going to do differently.
I am going to take more
questions during class.
The slides are going to be
printed in this new format
so it's easier for you guys
to handle them and understand
them.
This is how office hours
are going to work now.
Basically he stood there and
addressed every single one
of our concerns in person.
And it was very validating
to hear that a professor
for this very large class--
professor on tenure
track who was just
getting used to style
of teaching at Harvard
was willing to hear
what we had to say,
and was willing to hear
the sort of evaluations
that we had for him, and really
took the time to critically
read everything that we said.
That being said,
I do think that--
echoing something that
Chris said earlier, not
all the student evaluations that
I believe that courses receive
are always in the best interest
of the students' learning,
in a sense.
I've also taken a class in the
humanities that is primarily
for freshmen and the
course is very challenging.
We read Joyce's
Ulysses in three weeks.
And we read Plato and
Macbeth and all these books,
like once--
like one book per
week basically.
It's a time-intensive
reading, intensive class.
And I think my year
was the second year
that it was being run.
And the year afterward it was
significantly easier I believe.
The workload was easier,
the final was easier.
And because of that I
think the course actually
became less rich for the
students who were involved
because the faculty
had decided to take
into account the evaluations
that were asking for the class
to be less time and less
of a stressful burden
on the students
come finals period.
But I really think that I got a
lot more out of the course when
it was more challenging.
I think in a sense,
students do have the power
to shape a lot about
how the course works,
but like Chris was saying
earlier, sometimes we
do worry a little bit too
much about the time constraint
or what it will do
towards GPA or the fact
that it's just a requirement
for our concentration.
I think it's worth having
those candid conversations
and keeping that in mind
with the evaluations.
Thanks, Disha.
You mentioned for
today that you really
value the Q Guide
as a student and yet
you just talked about
this discrepancy that
could exist between the
popularity of the professor
and maybe even how good he
or she-- how charismatic
he is in front of a classroom
with what you actually learn
in the class and that
those two may not always
correlate highly.
I wonder what it is
from the student side
that you value in the Q. What
do you look for when you are
shopping a course and
deciding, does this
look like something
I'm interested in?
What are you looking for in
this other students feedback?
I think the Q is
absolutely something that's
pretty critical for a
lot of students because--
especially freshmen,
they don't always
have a whole lot
of places to learn
about what a class is like
before they go into a shopping
week.
That being said, I do take the
Q Guide with a grain of salt
sometimes because the
evaluations that students give
are anatomised
and you don't know
exactly the background of some
students going into the class.
Say for example, I came from
a very strong life sciences
background in high school.
I've taken-- I took organic
chemistry in high school
and because of that,
my experience going
into organic chemistry
in freshman year
was very different
from some of the things
that the Q Guide was
saying, which was like,
oh, this class is awful, it's
going to wreck your life,
it's going to be
way too difficult
for you to take as a freshman.
It's just something
to keep in mind.
And I do think that
there are classes that
will be rated highly that are--
that I think potentially are
rated highly just because
of the personality of the
professor or because of--
for example, there's one
particular science class
that normally gets really
pretty high Q scores,
but gets that because the
professor is really funny, not
necessarily because the class
is particularly well taught,
it's just because her
lectures are enjoyable.
When I look at the Q
Guide as a student,
I really value to find out the
Q shows the amount of hours that
go into the class per week.
Because as busy
students, everyone
wants to know how to budget
their time on average.
And I also really value what
the students individually
have to say.
I think faculty
sometimes get asked
like is the Q even useful?
They wonder whether the
students even use it.
I think it's very useful.
I think I have not really seen
any courses that don't release
Q scores, but when
they don't it makes
me wonder what is there about
the course that I should know?
What is it that
the faculty doesn't
want me to see basically?
Umm so yeah.
I have a question for Signa
kind of informed by the comment
that Disha just made.
I've never taken
a law class and so
I don't know what your standard
is for giving evaluation
feedbacks.
And nothing just about Harvard
and the experience so far,
when you think back about any of
the work that you did earlier,
how do you actually
give feedback?
Is it just the end
of the semester?
Eval, and then how do you
know if faculty factor that in
or keep them accountable to it.
The law school
model is typically--
you get feedback at the end.
It's something like a
Q Guide system where--
for GW for instance,
you would rank
the hours, the effectiveness
of the lectures,
teachers knowledge of the
course, student engagement
participation.
And then you had a box where you
could give individual comments
and feedbacks either to the
teacher and then just students
who are considering the class.
The second-- that tends to
be pretty much everywhere.
I will say, one thing I was
so shocked about Harvard Law
is that apparently
it's not online.
I think they're moving
towards that direction,
but I will say, choosing
classes for the semester was
terrible trying to
figure out what to take.
What do I know about
these professors?
Some of it-- they have
some of it online,
but ultimately it's just
not all together in a space
that I think it
really should be.
But basically trying--
I use it a lot.
I use that feedback, especially
the individual comments at GW
based on what students
have said about the class.
If they say, if you--
government contracts-- if
you have a broad interest
in this person's
a person for you
if you want something
that's more in depth
or specific or you know
that this is something
that you want to do, go
with a different professor.
Hearing that feedback and then
figuring it out is so helpful.
But in terms of
teacher-- the feedback
that teachers get and professors
get from those evaluations,
we have no idea whether
or not they take it
into consideration.
And I will say something
for me as a student--
and I think a lot of
my other classmates
think this is well, is it that
the tenure system sort of--
you write an
evaluation, especially
for your 1L doctrinal
classes where you say,
I didn't understand a
thing that this professor
was saying to me all semester.
I went to office hours,
he was grouchy and mean
and didn't help,
and I left the class
just being like, I
couldn't do this subject.
And then you know
nothing changes
because they've said
in the past, whatever,
you guys write whatever you
want in our course evals.
And there's no driving force for
them to change their curriculum
or change their teaching
methodology, which
is something that's
frustrating on a student.
And especially when--
I would say for
the first year you
don't get a choice in the
teachers and professors
that you get, your
placed into a class.
And you have to figure out
what that professors system is
and go with it, and
it's on you to do that.
And so when you get to
the end of the course,
a lot of the time
it comes down to you
ranting about all
of the injustices
that you feel like you went
through throughout the semester
and not necessarily
thinking that it's actually
going to have any effect on the
people who are going to come.
Thank you.
Thank you all for all
of your presentations.
One thing I was hearing
across the board
was just how important or
how positive of an experience
it was for you to
feel recognized,
feel like your voices mattered.
I'm coming as a French
professor so the opposite of--
I don't do lectures.
I'm teaching a seminar,
that means once a week.
In terms of what
format to choose,
or what format what might
work in making students
feel like their voices
have been heard,
I hesitate to devote one--
the semester's not
very long, it's
only about 12 teachable weeks
because the first week you
can't really do
anything with shopping.
And I hesitate to
take class time out,
which I don't have that much
of to go over the evaluations
because that means we're reading
one last novel that semester.
Can you think of alternatives
to taking class time away
to go over student feedback
that might still make you feel
recognized and listened to?
I think students do
read their emails
and do respond to office hours.
I think if there
were opportunities
to go talk to you in office
hours about feedback,
that might also be an option.
I don't necessarily
think that it
need to in lecture
or in your seminar
because I do understand that
seminars are very limited time
and what students value at
seminars is the learning,
not necessarily talking about
the feedback of the learning.
So
I think an email communication
is also totally fine.
I've had professors who've
done that in the past.
And we do read that
because obviously,
when your professor is
sending you something
you should probably
check that it is.
And maybe, I don't know, like
candid office hours may also
be an option, office hours
themed around the feedback.
I would second that,
particularly with office hours.
I've had professors
who after I ask
a question will ask how
do I feel about the class,
how do I feel like it's
going, and that opens up
the conversation.
And there are
definitely professors
where I know to be sort of
more, no, everything-- you know,
everything's fine.
Ultimately, more positive.
And there are other
professors who
I know are really
looking for the more
constructive criticism.
But having the opportunity
and having a professor prompt
you to give that in a
more one-on-one setting
makes it feel like
you're actually
having your voice heard.
Maybe a companion
question that--
and I know a couple
of you mentioned
that you've also
taught and so you've
been on the other side of
this system of evaluations.
And so have you ever as
a teacher, as a student,
have you been given a
mid-course evaluation?
So from the student
side where it really
didn't ask something
about something
that you cared deeply about?
And did that-- how did
that make you feel?
Were you frustrated by that?
And then on the other--
and as a student
did you ever answer
something on a mid-course
and not see it
addressed in the class
and what did you
feel about that?
And then from the
teacher side of things,
can you think about
why that might happen?
That disconnect of that either
you don't get asked something
or that you don't have
an opportunity to--
that you don't hear that your
feedback was really addressed?
I've been-- I don't--
we don't have mid-year
for PCMP, right?
We didn't do that.
OK, yeah, so I don't have a
specific answer to the question
of mid-year evaluations.
But I've been both
a student and a TA
for the second year
this time around.
In the first year
molecular biology
graduate course for my program.
I've seen the exact same
course for three years
now from both sides
and I think something
that the students sometimes--
when I was a student and
hearing feedback from students
in my section that I lead at
discussion section every two
weeks, is that
sometimes students
fail to really see the
reality of running a course.
And sometimes just during
informal, maybe halfway
through the semester,
I'll check in with people
and see how my
students are doing.
They'll bring up
points such as say,
changing the format
of problem sets
or changing the way
things are graded
or the weighting
of the grades that
really aren't things
that can be changed
in the middle of a course.
And while they might
be valid points,
I feel like sometimes
a mid-course evaluation
is going to solicit
comments that
are not necessarily helpful
to that year of the course.
And it might be more helpful--
and those mid-year
comments are going
to be more helpful really
for reminding students
and collecting their thoughts
while their thoughts are still
fresh on whatever
was being taught
around that mid-year period.
And so by the time you get to
the final course evaluation
they haven't forgotten what
they were experiencing.
Can I maybe follow up on that?
I think that's a great point.
A couple of the questions
that you guys did
a wonderful job writing
to spoke to when
is the most effective
time to ask for feedback?
And a couple people
suggested continuous.
Should it be a daily
journal that every day
I go home and say,
this class was awesome,
or I would have
changed this part?
Or could it even be
fun in that context?
Could it-- does it
always have to be
an arduous end of the
year soul searching thing?
Or can it be maybe a more
informal continuous thing?
I just want to open that to you.
Can I just add to that?
Maybe even after
the course is over,
allow some time to go by
so that you can really
reflect on what are the
lasting effects of that course.
I've had students who have
given a course a fair evaluation
at the very end, thought
about it over the summer
and come back and tell me it was
phenomenal because the takeaway
filtered through.
Those moments, those
high intensity moments
that may have come from
the class at any moment.
In fact, is that
more valuable for you
to reflect on after
some time has passed
and as you're maybe making
choices for what's the next--
what are the next courses
that I'm going to be taking?
I think I very much echo
exactly what you said.
I do think there is
some-- like right now
the Q scores are solicited
right before students
get their grades.
I do think there is some
logistical difficulties in that
once a student sees their
grade they may not feel
the same way about the course.
But I do think that
there are definitely
courses that I have
taken here, which
after teaching
subsequent courses,
I feel so much more grateful
for having to take--
I took MCD060 with Marty.
And that course, I'm
so grateful for having
taken because the
skills that I use
are now invaluable in higher
level graduate bio courses
that I'm taking.
I think that in and of
itself is a useful to think
about soliciting
feedback maybe a semester
after you've taken a
class, after you've
taken more advanced
classes in the same area.
But that being said,
that doesn't necessarily
have to get rid of the Q
scores being collected right
before the grades
because I do think
that there is some value
to a student reflecting
on the course before
getting something
on their transcript
that tells them
how they did in the course.
Actually, that reminds
me of something
that came up in the panel
this morning, which was
asking the alumni for feedback.
And so, Signa, I know you are
a Harvard alumnus and so are
there-- if you reflect back on
your undergraduate experience,
are there things that-- are
there courses that you took
that--
or information you've
retained or skills
you've retained from
your undergraduate years
that you now realize like,
oh, I didn't appreciate
that that same way when I was
going through it as I do now?
Definitely.
Actually, one of my
classes right now
tends to be more
politically science focused
and I was a social studies
undergrad major and had
to take this class my sophomore
year called social studies 10,
which everybody knows
is sort of a nightmare
and it's all social theory and
you just have to get through it
to get to the good stuff.
And going though this
class now really makes
me think back to
undergrad and thinking,
wow, I wish I had paid more
attention in social studies 10.
And it was just a
really good foundation
for learning how to read
text and sort of pick up
these ideas and
the main messages
from the authors, which I
thought I knew how to do
and then afterwards I was
like, no, actually now I
know how to do this better.
And looking back,
there are definitely
classes that stick out that
I think I didn't appreciate
at the time as much as I should
have and now very much value
having done.
The same thing, there are
also classes that I thought
were really interesting
during undergrad
and had sort of not
really contributed
much in terms of my
academic development,
but they were good all the same.
They're really
interesting, happy
that I took them, but definitely
not as productive or effective.
That adds an
interesting dimension
to this alumni
feedback piece, which
is that's great for all faculty
to know what my students retain
years out.
But also for students--
perspective students
in that class to hear
from the alumni who's
in law school saying, you might
think this class is a drag,
but you're going to really need
it, so pay attention to this.
OK.
I know we have a hard stop.
Everything-- these
were such rich stories
that our plans for
our interaction
evaporated because
I think we all
felt like we really
wanted to give
the students the voice in here.
So we top now.